QUORUM AND WE WILL GO OUT OF
ORDER AND WE'LL HEAR ITEM TWO,
SB SEVEN BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
FIRST. GO AHEAD, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT. SB SEVEN, WHICH WILL
MAKE MINOR CHANGES TO THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION OR ARENA DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. THESE CHANGES ARE BASED
ON FINDINGS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT, OR HCD, IN THEIR
ARENA. EVALUATION. SB SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS
TO SPECIFICALLY SOLICIT
PARTICIPATION FROM PEOPLE WITH
SPECIAL HOUSING NEEDS, INCLUDING
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNHOUSED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ARENA
METHODOLOGIES. ADDITIONALLY, SB
SEVEN WILL SIMPLIFY STEPS IN THE
PROCESS AND ALIGN THE STATUTE
CLOSER TO HOW IT IS CURRENTLY
BEING APPLIED. OVERALL, THESE
CHANGES WILL STRENGTHEN THE
ARENA PROCESS AND CLARIFY THE
STATUTE. I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
A WITNESS HERE WITH ME TODAY,
BUT I DON'T SEE HER. OKAY. YOU
CAN JUST. I WILL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. GREAT ALL
RIGHT. THE, WHEN WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. WITH A QUORUM, THEN
THE, MOTION THAT I WOULD
ENTERTAIN IS THAT ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN, SO
WE'LL NOW JUST WAIT UNTIL WE CAN
GET OUR. OH, OF COURSE YOU CAN.
I DIDN'T SEE YOU PUT YOUR HAND
UP. SO IT SAYS THAT THIS BILL
PROHIBITS A CITY OR COUNTY FROM
FILING AN OBJECTION TO THE, THE
ARENA PROCESS IN REGIONS IN
WHICH HCD IS REQUIRED TO ACT. IS
THAT BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY
ACTED IN THEIR. THEY'VE ALREADY
DETERMINED. SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THIS BILL DEALS
WITH THE ARENA ALLOCATION THAT
COMES FROM THE STATE TO THE COG.
RIGHT. AND THEN IT GOES FROM THE
COG TO THE CITIES, CITIES AND
COUNTIES. SO THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A CHALLENGE WHEN IT COMES
FROM THE COG, BUT NOT TO
INTERVENE WHEN IT'S COMING FROM
THE STATE TO THE COG. SO IT'S
BASICALLY, IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT LEVEL THIS, THAT,
THAT IS DEALING WITH. BUT THE
COG IS THE GO BETWEEN BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE AND THE
CITIES. RIGHT. WITHOUT THE COG
IN AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE IT,
WHO'S THERE? WHO DO THEY OBJECT
TO? WHO DO THEY MAKE AN ARGUMENT
TO THAT THEIR ALLOCATION IS
UNFAIR? I DON'T THINK THERE ARE
CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE A GO
BETWEEN BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE CITY. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S A THE COUNTY THAT'S ACTING
IN THAT ROLE OR IF ALL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE A COG. BUT I
DON'T THINK IT GOES DIRECTLY
FROM A STATE TO A CITY. SO THAT
WOULDN'T EVEN APPLY BECAUSE NO
COUNTY OR CITY DOESN'T HAVE A
COG THAT THEY BELONG TO. OR WHY
IS THE LANGUAGE EVEN IN THERE?
I'M JUST CURIOUS. I THINK THE
NEED WAS TO CLARIFY THAT THE
CITIES DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
INTERVENE BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE COG. SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
IDENTIFIED PROBLEM THAT THIS IS
SOLVING. SO ONLY THE COG CAN
INTERVENE WITH THE STATE OR MAKE
AN OBJECTION. BUT IF THE CITY
AND THE COG DON'T AGREE, THE
CITY DOESN'T GET TO MAKE THEIR
OBJECTION TO HCD. I MEAN, THE
COG IS MADE UP OF THE CITIES.
OH, I KNOW IT'S MADE UP OF
SEVERAL CITIES, BUT ONE CITY MAY
OBJECT THAT SOMETIMES ALL THE
CITIES IN THE COG DO NOT
REPRESENT A CITY, RIGHT? WELL,
SO THEY CAN GANG UP ON THAT CITY
AND MAKE IT REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
THEM. AND THAT'S, THAT'S I
THINK, WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
CITIES HAVE EVERY AVENUE TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT RELATES TO
THIS. RIGHT? I MEAN, I THINK IN
GENERAL, HAVING A PROCESS WHERE
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE AND THEN THE BODY
MAKES A DECISION AND THEN THE
NEXT LEVEL MAKES A DECISION IS
HOW WE'VE DISTRIBUTED
RESPONSIBILITY HERE. SO WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INTERVENE FOR ALL PARTIES AT ALL
LEVELS. SO TO ME THIS DOES MAKE
SENSE. AS A PROCESS. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR, FOR
GIVING. THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
GIVING, THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
QUESTIONING OF THIS BILL.
CERTAINLY ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON IT? I DIDN'T ASK
FOR THOSE IN TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO COME TO THE MIC INTO Þ?
MY WITNESS IS HERE. SO DO YOU
MIND IF SHE GIVES HER? SURE.
SURE. YES, CAN. THIS IS HOLLY.
LET ME TAKE QUORUM FIRST AND
THEN ANSWER. OKAY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR SKINNER. I'M
HERE. SKINNER. HERE. OCHOA.
BOGH. BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE. SPEER.
POLICE SAY HERE. I PRESENT.
PRESENT. HERE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR
HERE. PADILLA YES. SENATOR. SAY.
HERE OKAY. WE NOW HAVE QUORUM.
OUR WITNESS CAN, TELL CHAIR TO
HEAR, WE HAVE HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY. WE CAN NOW HAVE
OUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GO
AHEAD. HOLLY. FOR MANY
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS, ON
BEHALF OF THE INNER CITY LAW
CENTER AND SPUR AND SUPPORT,
JUST RECOMMEND, AND I VOTE.
THESE ARE GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM HCD. AND THE BEST THING WE
CAN DO TO HELP BUILD MORE
HOUSING IS HELP ENFORCE THE
HOUSING ELEMENT AND THE PLANNING
PROCESS THAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
CITY LEVEL. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION?
NO. SEEING NONE. AND AGAIN I'LL
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS. WE
THIS IS. WE DID IT, OUT OF
ORDER. AND WE DID THE SECOND
BILL FIRST, WHICH IS SENATOR
BLAKE SPEERS AND I HAVE AN.
EXCUSE ME, I HAVE AN I
RECOMMENDATION, AND I WILL NOW
ENTERTAIN A MOTION THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN. SO MOVED. RIGHT. MENGIBAR
MOVES. SORRY. MAY WE HAVE THE
ROLL CALL, PLEASE? OR. EXCUSE
ME, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WE'LL DO ROLL CALL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SEVEN BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN SENATOR SKINNER. I
SKINNER, I OCHOA, BOGH BLAKE.
SPEER BLAKE. SPEER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ. I CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR I PADILLA I PADILLA I
CIERTO CIERTO NÓ UMBERG WAHAB
WAHHAB I. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON. CALL AND ANYBODY
HAVE MISS CHAVEZ, NUMBER TEXT
HER BECAUSE SHE'S KEEPING US
FROM DINNER. OKAY. BARBECUE EVEN
WORSE. THANK IT IS. NOW I'M
HAVING TO EAT IT ALL. ANXIETY, I
KNOW, IS THAT IT IS ALL FROM
FIRE SERVICE STAFF. I'VE BEEN
TESTING MYSELF.
YOU GUYS BROUGHT ME WITH ALL
YOUR TEXTS. PROBABLY SLOWED HER
DOWN. I KNOW I WAS STANDING
THERE TYPING. COULDN'T WALK.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE ARE
READY AND EAGER TO HEAR YOUR
BILL. AB 535 AND YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF VETERANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ENCINO. A
SIGNIFICANT STEP WAS TAKEN LAST
YEAR TOWARDS EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY OF VETERANS TO THE
VETERAN HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM, OR V-CHIP,
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
INCOME VETERANS MAY RECEIVE
THROUGH DISABILITY BENEFITS.
EVEN MORE RECENTLY, FEDERAL
REGULATORY CHANGES HAVE EXCLUDED
VETERANS DISABILITY BENEFITS
FROM INCOME CALCULATIONS FOR
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY FOR
VETERANS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
VOUCHERS. HOWEVER, WITHOUT
CONFORMING VÆ VA TO THOSE
CHANGES, VETERANS WHO WOULD NOW
BE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL HOUSING
VOUCHERS WILL FIND THEMSELVES
TURNED AWAY YET AGAIN FROM
CALIFORNIA'S VETERAN HOUSING
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISABILITY BENEFITS. AB 535 IS A
NECESSARY AND SIMPLE FIX THAT
WILL CLEAR THE WAY AND CLEAR
AWAY ANY OBSTACLES TO GETTING
VETERANS INTO NEEDED, SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT. NO. ALL
RIGHT. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 535? OKAY
SEEING NONE, WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO A
PROPS, ANY QUESTIONS? DOES
ANYONE ON THE DÍAS HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO? WE ALREADY GOT TO MOVE.
WELL, I WISH I HAD A REALLY
SEARING QUESTION, BUT I DON'T.
OKAY SO YOU MAY CLOSE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EXCELLENT. WE WILL NOW DO A ROLL
CALL AGAIN. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
SKINNER. I SKINNER, I OCHOA.
BOGH. BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR
I CABALLERO. I CABALLERO. I
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I PADILLA. PADILLA I
CIERTO. CIERTO. I UMBERG. I
UMBERG I WAHAB. WAHAB I. IT'S 10
TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS
OUT THE OR. EXCUSE ME. WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ROLL OPEN. LET
ME REOPEN THE ROLL FOR THE BILL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SO WE'LL
REOPEN THE ROLL ON. MISS BLAKE
SPEARS. BILL, SB SEVEN, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 7 TO 1. SENATOR OCHOA
BOGH HAMBURG I UMBERG I 8 TO 1.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE ARE AWAITING
JUST UNDER. JUST SENATOR. OKAY.
PERFECT. THANKS, DAVE.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLL FIRST ON, AB 535, ITEM
ONE BY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO.
AND THE MOTION WAS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ABSENT MEMBERS,
CALL THE CURRENT VOTE IS 10 TO
0. SENATOR. OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI I
11 TO 0. EXCELLENT. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 10 TO 0. 10 TO 0. AB 535
OUT, 10 TO 0. NOW WE'LL OPEN THE
ROLL ON SB SEVEN. AND THE MOTION
THERE WAS THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN. YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER CURREN.
VOTE IS 8 TO 1. SENATOR OKOBOJI.
NO. NO, 8 TO 2. ALL RIGHT. THE
THAT BILL IS OUT. SB SEVEN AND
THE VOTE WAS 8 TO 2. OKAY AND
WITH THAT OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU. STAFF
THANK YOU. NEXT.